[Music]
welcome to the view from 22 from The
Spectator I'm Fraser Nelson Nicholas
sturon has been giving evidence to the
Scottish covid inquiry has had the eyes
of the country back on the dysfunction
that's been going on inside her
government for levels of secrecy the
level of clownishness and what we
describe in this week's cover story as
mcmafia a again of gangsterism which
supplanted what should have been
government somebody who knows a lot
about that is Alex salmon Nicholas
duron's predecessor who we feature on
the cover of the magazine um he's not
exactly part of her group but certainly
was a victim of it now Alex I think
we've committed a cardinal offense here
of um putting you here in a kilt in the
front cover you never were a kilt do you
you're more of a a Tartan TRS man hey I
have want a i wor K an event called
dressed to Kilt so I thought under the
circumstance but that was in New York so
I I can wear it away from home right but
broadly speaking was this a fair
headline or was it unfair no it's well I
mean look it's a cartoon it's a headline
you're a you're a magazine what's meant
to be fair about it I mean all fair it's
all fears and politics and the and
magazines I do object to the say I mean
I should be much much more prominent in
the picture of course but uh apart from
that I'll just I'll just treat it as a
cartoon humza doesn't look very happy
and after the revelations at the quir
that he felt he had a punishment beating
from Nicholas's first Minister that's
probably why maybe that was after his
punishment meeting but the overall theme
though that I've seen coming out of the
co inquiry is the way that Nicholas
Duran seems to have put secrecy right at
the heart of her covid response there
was um the H civil servants talking
about how plausible Deni plausible
deniability is my middle name you've got
other people comparing notes and how to
delete whatsapps you've got the
Revelation that she deleted hers it
seems that an awful lot of um of
importance has been placed on how to
basically Dodge public scrutiny uh now
you yourself have been on the wrong side
of this law haven't you well yes a
disentangle that they you're right I
mean the Scottish government have not
emerged from the co inquiry with any
credit uh and the mass deletion the
systematic industrial deletion of
whatsapps is uh probably the the point
of all and this is remember what's
interesting here is Nichol ston gave a
specific commitment on one of the co
briefings that everything would be
retained and that was in August
2021 uh and the mass deletion policy
seems to have come into effect in
2022 so that is very difficult to
explain in any other way but that uh
there was lots of stuff in the whatsapps
that they didn't want to see the light
of day the one thing I would say this is
not something unique to the Scottish
government I mean Boris Johnson hasn't
handed over any whatsapps the current
prime minister hasn't handed over any
whatsapps at all to the inquiry so this
attention to secrecy as opposed to
attention to detail is not confined to
Edinburgh it seems to be manifest in
London as well but there's no Mass
deletion in London that we've come
across and to the contrary we've seen
every single thought that M hanok had
over this period unfortunately yes right
but you know there is no deficits of of
scrutiny or knowledge of what was being
said behind the scenes there when you
come to Scotland though you do seem to
notice a difference you first of all
have got Nicholas dur as you say saying
on camera that should keep it whatsapps
then going on to delete them you also
notice the difference in the Civil
Service as well to have civil servants
talk in that way as if they were part of
a secrecy conspiracy was quite striking
I mean it's one thing for special
advisers to say that but civil servants
well I mean most of the civil servants
who raised objections in London have
been dispatched to the House of Lords
and elsewhere the current cabinet seor
because is zill not able to attend
anything and previous top civil servants
were promptly sacked when Boris Johnson
came into his administration you know
frer you're talking about things which
are not particularly uh proper they
don't show the Scottish government in a
good light at all it wouldn't have
happened under my Administration unless
you can point to the contrary H but uh
it's not unique to to the Scottish
government I me the same things are
manifest in London and you say Matt uh
Hancock held on to his whatsapps
probably to write his book but Kate
Forbes held on to her whatsapps humza
held on to some of his uh and
unfortunately for Nicholas sturgeon her
senior special advisor Liz Lloyd held on
to her so there's not even though even
though there was a policy for deletion
that policy doesn't seem to have been
adhered to in all cases but this
difficulty the cental difficulty I would
suggest as Nicolas sturon is the only
person who went to a press conf
conference promised Faithfully that
everything would be retained and then
didn't right but when I'm watching all
this I am thinking back to um you know
25 years ago when Devolution started now
I was then um a young reporter in was
got Parliament um you were um leader of
the
opposition and and you you my point when
look back at the idealism which a lot of
people have for Devol I was certainly
one of those who's really enthusiastic
about it and I thought the following
things I thought there'd be greater
scrutiny I thought there'd be local the
decision- making Not only would be
closer to the people but better
scrutinized by the parliament I thought
there would be a greater sense of
ownership and transparency and it seems
the other way around
um well it's not the other way around
phraser it's just
that in certain respects the Scottish
Parliament hasn't lived up to its own
high ideals and high standards I mean
let's let's not be around Bush yet I
mean the the the number of people even
after the last fairly TD couple of years
of Revelations about the current
Administration uh the number of people
in Scotland who don't think you're
better off with a parliament as opposed
to not having one is minuscule uh the
number of people who trust the Scottish
Parliament to act in the interest of
Scotland compared to Westminster is
about 4 to1 it's just that the Scottish
Parliament is not riding as high in
public esteem as it was for example in
10 years ago H but they've they seem to
have captured some bad habits from
Westminster now one of the worst things
I suspect is this that they wanted to
claim during Co that things were doing
being done so much better in Scotland
than they were at Westminster and it was
an easy political hit because the Prime
Minister then prime minister Boris
Johnson's presentation was chaotic as
has been confirmed by many whatsapps and
other Revelations so therefore Nicholas
ston whose presentation seems so ordered
composed reassuring and the public face
of the pandemic look much better managed
in Scotland than London the problem is
twofold one is the actual underlying
policy was very similar there wasn't
that much difference in policy just a
difference in presentation and some in
some ways that's not the fault of
Scottish government because you're
limited in how you can diverge when the
funding is coming from the treasury but
the second thing is behind the under the
scuts of government behind the scenes uh
you know people have seem to been acting
with something similar in terms of their
personal motivations and personal
criticism of colleagues now you might
just say this is the actions of people
who are under great pressure you know
they blow their top they get angry with
colleagues they say things on whatsapps
but if you're the worst thing in
politics is to pretend to be holier than
now uh and then to be to be found out
you're just as bad as the rest of them
on the central theme of my mcmafia
argument was the way that they behave in
secrecy almost like a gangsterism now
you have been on the wrong side of that
you um
I still remember the drama we had not so
long ago where you had you published
your side of a story which was redacted
not published by the Scottish Parliament
um and The Spectator went to the court
of appeal to see if we can get a ruling
whether you can be published or not
thing is that's quite a pava for simply
um one man presenting his case so I put
it to you that I'm not this my analysis
is not um unionist malevolence there is
actually a transparency problem with the
Scottish government and you yourself
have been the victim of that well I mean
I said in my opening to my evidence to
the inquiry that in my view that uh that
some of the institutions of Scotland
particularly the crown office and the
Parliament uh had failed the country and
certain individuals within them had
failed uh I don't think the idea of the
parliament failed the idea of uh of
Scottish Devolution and then Parliament
failed but some of the people in these
institutions people like the crown agent
you know who's taking the decision about
prosecution of The Spectator or opposing
The Spectator magazine or a civil case
against The Spectator people who are
bearing down in parliamentary committees
when in the most best ordered
democracies you know parliamentary
committees should Bear Down on the
institutions regardless of who they are
without fear or favor under total
privilege as opposed to vice versa now
that tells me that we need to make
changes to protect the institutions
against having bad eggs in charge of
them yeah I mean it's too weak isn't it
it's got we saw during your case the
that the Committees members were told
but they basically are not protected by
parliamentary privilege as they are in
Westminster they were told they better
they were told they better not ask
questions about your case because if
they got on the wrong side of the law
they'd be prosecuted now it's
Unthinkable that you as an MP down here
would be told that and I put to you this
is simply a flaw in Devolution that the
Scottish Parliament doesn't have the
powers it needs to scrutinize the
government I think you're right to an
extent I have to say that I would never
have accepted such an instruction as an
MSP never mind an MP right but the
threat can still be made and correctly
so it's it's a it's partly it's a
Personnel problem uh I mean and I have
to say you I missed this to a great
extent I mean I reckon if you appointed
the right people you know you appointed
the right Lord Advocate and right Lord
Advocates as I appointed that the system
would run properly unfortunately if you
appointed the wrong one or the wrong
Crown agent things don't work and it's
particularly don't work if you get
people who are anxious to please their
political Masters as opposed to doing
their job s and maybe I mean it is an
argument that as a single political
party stays in office over a a long
period of time then people find
themselves unable to make the
distinction between the party and the
government and I don't think again
that's a Scottish issue but I do think
you're on to something when you say the
institutions of government need to be
strengthened not weakened but
strengthened the parliament needs to be
strengthened and the the separation of
the prosecutorial authorities from the
advice to to the the cabinet and first
Minister needs to be made absolutely
delineated and clear I mean for example
I took the Law Officers out of the
Scottish cabinet they only came if they
were asked on a point of Law and then no
no no no but this after I left office
they were back in again uh under the
next Lord advocate so you know the the
process I thought well okay it seems to
me sensible to keep these things
separate so let's do it in practice I
should have done it theu as where was
the fact right because there should be
separation of Law and other government
and I I I put to you that that was a
flaw in the Devolution settlement that
the powers were not separated as they
should be correct and uh you know I mean
I suppose if you had your time over
again there's certain things you would
do and certain things you wouldn't do
and that's one of the things I would do
having said that but we got through a a
fair amount in the time I was in office
now when Devolution came along I thought
to myself well this is what we need
because Scotland has got an incredible
Pro U problem with ingrained poverty in
Glasgow and on the enve wrongs with drug
abuse um train spotting had made world
famous that problem and during the next
years rather than get better I've got a
graph here of which you'll be very
familiar which is just how um drugs
deaths then Rose significantly um you
know you don't need be sure to you be
very familiar with this now what then so
Scotland's drug deaths ended up becoming
not just the highest in the UK the
highest of anywhere in a developed world
it's quite interesting the the the sharp
rise as you can see is is towards the
end of that
graph there are certain aspects of drug
deaths which are historic I mean the
people who die of of drug abuse in many
cases have been doing it for decades but
they Tri I but just let me finish this
point
phaser as first Minister looking at the
array of uh of health and social issues
facing Scotland it's true that I I've
been obviously drugs was hugely
important I mean there had been
campaigns on drugs you know back as long
as I could remember and they continued
and people argued you know back and
forward about them to me the the the
prevailing difference back in 2007 2011
it was alcohol abuse it was uh you know
you know Scotland it's still pretty bad
yeah but it you know it has it has uh
moderated in terms of uh of the level of
abuse and we introduced minimum pricing
which was a a significant and courageous
uh courageous move so certain aspects of
Public Health in Scotland have been
improving one other aspect you know we
could point to Great successes and great
favors there's no doubt that you know
everybody right through that graph
should be should be thinking about uh
the extent to which the the drugs death
has increased more than other countries
but for example knife crime in Scotland
you know when it's an epidemic
proportions right now in English City I
it was reduced by
75% in three years under the leadership
of Kenny mka was Justice secretary and
incident that formula that could be used
in life CL could be used in England in
my estimation and could be reintroduced
in Scotland because it slipped back
right is there an answer to to a basic
question which is why drugs deaths
should be so much higher so much higher
in Scotland than anywhere else in the
world well I think there's probably
three reasons one is that uh measurement
uh uh I'm not certain that many other
countries measure drug deaths as
assiduously as Scotland does uh that's
one aspect the rest of the UK does well
I'm not even sure about that but
certainly there's a measurement issue
secondly the level I mean drugs drug
abuse is deeply linked to substantial
pockets of of social deprivation I every
pattern shows that Scotland's had some
sustained pockets of deprivation and
there after the drug abuse in these
areas and thirdly that the policy
prescription in Scotland which is
basically being to to moderate the
extremity of the problem through a huge
method program does not over long period
moderate drugs deaths it it it amates
the impact of substantial drug abuse
across Society but it doesn't mitigate
as we see the eventual deaths of people
who are abusing drugs so you need a
substantial New Direction I should say
just in my defense that the extremity of
the three times you know occurred
somewhat later on but this isn't about
my point here isn't so much about even
about the S&P this is just about the
institution of devolution and they
extend 25 years on if Scots as you say
they're very happy to Parliament they
wouldn't reverse it but can we really
say can we really say the schools of all
the explanations that all the world we
might look at as to as to why Scotland
has this extraordinary problem with drug
abuse I don't think the Advent of the
Scottish parliament in 1999 is one of
the causal factors well I'm wondering
why it trebled it didn't need to be that
way well well I think it trebled because
there was a a
longstanding problem of abuse which
results what you're measuring there is
drug deaths you're not drug measuring
people who are currently drug abusers
you're imagining people who die of drug
abuse many people die of some people die
very quickly incidentally but some
people many people die over a long
period of abuse particularly when
they've been on medication which has
ameliorated the immediate impact of the
substance and abuse and that mean that's
just a fact I mean so a lot of that jump
there is historic into the past I mean
if I don't have no reason why I should
have the figures to hand at the present
moment but if you did an analysis of
people dying now asking when they they
first abusing the substances of which
they eventually died you'll find it
stretches back many years almost decades
my over can I ask you one one final
point to you now you know I mean you're
put him in position of of doing that
think this is not about Alex Simon's
time in office this is about de in
general whether nor nor do I want to say
look everything went pearshaped in the
last 10 years I mean I might believe
that but nonetheless I don't want to say
it you know the point I'm making to you
is this that I don't think over the last
when is that that's uh 30 40 years that
Scotland has got the right formula uh
for making a real impact on the extent
of drug abuse in the country however
there are certain social and economic
ills in Scotland where we did discover
the right formula and one of these was
knife crime in the years from 2008 to
2015 16 right of course many things have
got better in 25 years in Scotland of
course they have the question is where
can you point to the difference that
Devolution has made where can you point
to these Scottish solutions for Scottish
problems that have materially improved
the lives of the people in Scotland
right now it seems doesn't it that we've
had another channel of political
entertainment that is new we see
Hollywood we see a Rogues Gallery we see
people like you stitched up by the
mcmafia of Nicholas juron we see a
culture of secrecy we see all sorts of
um problems in Hollywood we don't really
see this with Scottish parents thinking
isn't it fantastic that um our schools
here are so great instead they're
turning to private tutors in never
greater numbers where Civ scottage NHS
is not doing particularly well either um
we even during Co we had a response
where the number of proportion people
dying in Care Homes was far greater than
it was in England it doesn't really seem
as if home rule has proved much of
success or a basis on which you can
reasonably claim to want independence
well except of course in 2014 we we
fought our independence referendum we
one of we one of the yes I'm just I'm
not going to try to change history on
you but if you allow me to interrupt
your question just
occasionally that uh that we one of the
strongest Arguments for Independence in
that referendum was the success of
Scottish government policy across a
range of issues you know the the
Scottish governance has had a bad period
over a few years but over the pieace and
over the 25 years the vast majority of
people say far better with a parliament
without one and there have been periods
in that in that quarter Century where
the difference between Scotland and
Westminster was outstanding and
incidentally in 2014 you weren't
comparing Scottish Governors with a
bunch of uh numpties at Westminster you
weren't comparing yourself with Boris
Johnson you weren't comparing yourself
with L trust you're comparing yourself
with what looked like a very reasonably
competent administration of uh of
Cameron and Osborne you know whichever
you know I don't remember you using that
phrase at the time no I disagreed very
substantially with David Cameron and
George Osburn across a range of issues
but I mean they look like a prime
minister and they look like a Chancellor
I mean it's a while since you've been
able to say that about UK Governors
brexit has made it harder though hasn't
it to make the case for Independence
because you would be saying let's go
back into the EU look at for Northern
irelandish you nobody wants that a
Scottish border that's why there's no
economic case for Independence anymore
it wasn't even produced so well I'm just
trying to work out what's actually wrong
with the Windsor house agreement apart
from the fact that Democratic unionists
don't like it for Pol IAL reasons there
certainly no economic sign that the
Windsor house agreement or being part of
the single Market is damaging the
economy of Northern Ireland I mean if
anything the evidence points to the
contrary uh I I think it would be in
fact one of the complaints I would have
about Nicholas sturgeon's Administration
is when offered the opportunity after
2017 when Theresa May's majority was was
a knife edge and she couldn't get the
support of her own party for a a less
brutal brexit deal
the opportunity was probably there to
take Scotland into a Northern Ireland
type relationship which I think would
have had great advantages for the the
Scottish economy in fact I don't think
there would be many companies in the
financial and other sectors who wouldn't
be hot footing at to Edinburgh at the
present moment if Scotland were both
part of a single market and had a
preferential position within the UK
Market which is approximately what
Northern island has at the present
moment right but the support for
Independence has barely moved on 10
years since you've had the referendum
what you mean is that the last poll show
it at 52% which is a very large section
of the population Fraser you know if I
if I had had a poll when we started the
independence campaign proper in 2012 the
the Edinburgh agreement that showed
Independence support at 52% as opposed
to the poll showing it at 28% which it
was there which it was then I would have
given my it for that I mean you got more
than half a population despite
everything you've mentioned who think
Independence is a good idea what a a
fantastic base from which to to to to to
to pursue the the summit of of Scottish
so it's still going to happen in your
lifetime is it oh yeah I mean you know
the you know politicians could make a
real muck of things you know they they
can they can rough H things how they
will but what really matters is the
underlying base of support for Scottish
independence that that's that's what's
the the Bedrock you'll get politicians
at some point who'll organize their
Affairs in such a way
has to take that obvious political
advantage and bring it to a reality
right but I mean I remember you saying
once free by 93 that was one of your
slogans well it was actually Alec Neil
and a slogan with with J sers which I
didn't altogether approve of as Alec
will tell you but nonetheless it showed
a level of ambition of course which I
approved not necessarily a time scale
which I thought was realistic all right
um and can I ask the next election the
pools are pretty Grim for the S&P
suggesting they'll be down to 18 seats
that's a pretty big loss will this be
made worse by your Alba party are you
going to be splitting the votes and
meaning fewer nationalist MPS in West no
I think they will choose our seats
carefully we're going to intervene about
a dozen
constituencies I think it's important I
mean the reason for an intervention
which wasn't necessary as you know for
the last year I've been trying to
persuade Hamza YF of the advantages of
having a single independent candidate in
each
constituency uh you know whether it be a
couple of alipa candidates or Angus
Brenan M and Ne and in the western
Islands there been big advantages in
doing that but you know for reasons best
known to himself H didn't think that was
a good idea and now isn't actually going
to stand on an independence platform I
mean that this general election is the
first election since arguably
1987 where the S&P hasn't stood on an
explicit Independence platform you mean
it hasn't said that a vote for the SNP
is a vote for Independence correct well
they they say I vote for the S&P if I
interpret the resolution from the
conference correctly is I vote for a
democratic effect not absolutely certain
what that means so you're 12
interventions by which I mean you mean
candidates and the reason for having 12
candidates is alipa and others support
the view that in the absence of a
referendum route to Independence then
you should do two things one you should
treat electoral contest the ones that
elections are going to happen as we did
of course in the days before Devolution
as looking for an explicit Independence
mandate and secondly the Scottish
Parliament deprived of the opportunity
to hold the referendum that it it should
hold it should hold a referendum with
incompetence hasn't been deprived of the
opportunity have a referendum anytime it
once well they the they they could call
for one it hasn't well they could call
for one but they couldn't actually do
one they well I'm just making the point
there is a referendum you can hold with
incompetence haven't been denied it as
always say well but well okay the
Supreme Court uh ruled against the
Scottish government now I would never
have gone to the Supreme Court but we
are where we are and well what would I
have done Fraser if David ceron in
2012 hadn't said yeah let's go down the
section 30 Route that's an agreement we
can have then what I would have done was
to hold a referendum which was within
the competence of the parliament where
you would stand a great chance of
resisting a legal Challenge and that's
is a a referendum about the powers of
the parliament and in particular that
the parliament should have the powers to
decide in Independence now I'm just
saying now if you combine a referendum
like that with a direct appeal for a
mandate in an election then you have a
very very powerful Democratic argument
for uh for Scottish independ who's
saying a vote for Alba will be a vote
for Independence so people who want to
express there vot for Scottish
independence at the next general
election will be able to vote for the
Alba party in the Dozen seats where you
can be bothered to stand well listen
fras if alip is a young political party
and there's no point in pretending can
you not find um 72 59 yeah the is it's I
mean it's gone down a bit since you're
showing your age it's now it's now at 57
it's like just remember hin soup and you
get the number of seats right H the
there's a difference between you know
you can't you can't run before you can
walk I mean ala's key Target obviously
is the elections in two years time where
every person in Scotland will have on
the voter's role will have the
opportunity to vote for an alipa
candidate and a direct mandate for
Independence for us the general election
is a means of exploring and introducing
to the people the argument we've just
discussed that you should vote directly
for an independence mandate to negotiate
independence of Westminster and you
should mobilize the political will to
bring that into effect I mean the
Scottish government is lacking a lot of
things at the present moment but more
than any other single Factor they're
lacking the political will to bring into
effect what they've been promising the
Scottish people for a number of years I
was in the Scottish Parliament I was
reported in the Scottish Parliament when
you made your first comeback and I
remember that quite well this was after
I forgot it was one I think a labor MSP
in burnt down curtains in a hotel there
was some Scandal well it was actually a
labor peer by Lord Watson and an MSP no
he was yes he probably he was you might
be right he was an MSP and a pi but my
point is and they kept his seat in the
house of Lord yeah but I remember you
saying a lot of people said of course if
you just owned up and said look I was
trying to get rid of the Scottish
political class and no jury would have
convict it would have been fine but you
came back after that was one of several
sort of low-level depressing scandals
that had been and I remember you saying
that you had high hopes for Devolution
and this the way it's turned out was
really quite low grade it was depressing
it was beneath the Dignity of the
project of a Scottish Parliament and you
wanted to come back as leader to try to
lift the Ambitions to restore that I'm
wondering what you think now surveying
what we've seen in the co inquiry
surveying what we've seen in the last
few years I wonder what you think now
about the Devolution project versus
where it could have been well I'm
thoroughly in favor of the parliament
I'm thoroughly in favor of Independence
in terms of governance I think it's time
that we got some growing UPS back into
the room if I have spoke in June 2014
and said look first minister in 10 years
time there will be an attempt to
imprison you to remove you as a
political threat and that you will
you're about to encounter the secrecy
and the kind of um the dark dealings in
your party and that will go on to shock
Scotland what would you said then well I
wouldn't have believed you obviously uh
and um you get older and wiser in these
things the one thing I'm determined to
do is undo these dark Forces to well
let's use a a good old northeaster
Scotland phrase to mck out the
buyer on that note Alex Amon thank you
very
[Music]
much